معنا الان من مستشفى ناصر في خانيونس
مراسل الجزيره وائل الدحدوح وائل تشتد
العمليات في خانيونس تحديدا كيف تبدو هذه
العمليات وايضا كيف تبدو اثارها على
المواطنين
[موسيقى]
هناك اذا ما بدانا بالناحيه الاخرى من
الصوره وهي الاشتباكات التي تدور بين
المقاومين الفلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي فان الامر هو الاخر يشتد
وضربات المقاومين الفلسطينيين تشتد وتتركز
اكثر فاكثر وتتسع رقعتها هذهه المره في
منطقه الزنه شرق خانيونس جنوبي قطاع غزه
حيث اعلنت كتائب القسام عن استهداف منزل
تحصن فيه جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي واوقع
هذه القوه المتحصن في هذا المنزل ما بين
قتيل وجريح وهناك ايضا سبق ذلك اعلان عن
استهداف الي او دبابه اسرائيليه ايضا في
منطقه الزنه شرق خان يونس بقذيفه ياسين
105 وهذا يندرج في سياق سلسله الضربات او
العمليات التي تنفذها المقاومه الفلسطينيه
احيانا بشكل مشترك لاسيما بين كتائب
القسام وسرايا القدس احيانا بشكل منفرد
كما هو الحال في بيانات القسام وايضا في
بيانات سرايا القدس التي قالت بانها ايضا
قصفت مناطق ومواقع للعدو اسرائيلي
وبالتالي هذه الضربات ما تزال مستمره وهذا
ربما يعكس ما نسمعه في الميدان من عمليات
تفجير عمليات اشتباكات واطلاق رصاص سواء
في ساعات الليل او حتى في ساعات النهار
وواضح بان عناصر المقاومه الفلسطينيه
تحاول ايقاع اكبر قدر ممكن من المفاجات ضد
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من خلال الوصول
الى مناطق خلف تعزيزات قوات الاحتلال وتمر
مركزها وبالتالي توجيه هذه الضربات الامر
الذي يمنح هؤلاء المقاومين دفعه معنويه
جديده وايضا يؤثر على معنويات جنود
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ولكن بالسلب بطبيعه
الحال عندما يتم تصوير هذه العمليات
العسكريه الفدائيه وبالتالي يتم نشرها هذا
الامر بالتاكيد يؤثر على معنويات جيش
الاحتلال وعلى المجتمع الاسرائيلي برمته
على ايه حال هذا جزء من الصوره الجزء
الاخر هو استمرار الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه
والمتمثله في في الغارات الاسرائيليه سواء
كان ذلك ضد منازل المواطنين التي عاده ما
تسفر عن شهداء وجرحى او تلك الغارات التي
تنبري لتنفيذها المسيرات الاسرائيليه التي
باتت تاخذ اهتماما متزايدا في صفوف جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ولذلك شاهدنا انه خلال الايام الماضيه
سلسله من من الغارات هي صاحبه العدد
الاكبر من الاستهدافات هذه المسيرات
لتستهدف مواطنين فلسطينيين مقاومين ونشطاء
وايضا سيارات ودراجات ناريه في مختلف
مناطق قطاع غزه اليوم ثمانيه شهداء وصلوا
الى مجمع ناصر الطبي جراء مجمل
الاستهدافات التي تمت حتى الان منذ ساعات
الصباح فقط وبالتالي هناك اعداد لم يتم
انتشالها باعتبار ان رقعه العمليات في
منطقه خانيونس او محافظه خانيونس تعتبر
واسعه نسبيا عميقه نسبيا بالشرق والغرب
وبالتالي كثير من المناطق لا تستطيع
سيارات الاسعاف الوصول لها وهذا يعرقل
يعني اعمال رجال الاسعاف وطواقم الدفاع
المدني وايضا يؤخر اتمام الاحصائيه وجعلها
دائما تتسم به اللحظيه والمؤقته وهذا امر
كما قلنا ديدا وربما صفه لا لازمه لكل
الاحداث في كل يوم وفي كل ساعه المنطقه
الوسطى بالتاكيد جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يوليها اهتماما بارزا ويركز عليها فيما
يتعلق بالاستهداف لا سما مخيمي المغازي
والبريج الذان يح يحدان شارع صلاح الدين
الذي يقسم قطاع غزه الى غرب وشرق وبالتالي
تعمد قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيل على مدار
الايام الاخيره على التركيز على قصف
واستهداف هذين المخيمين بالقصف المدفعي
وبالغت الاسرائيليه
وبالمسيح سكان هذا المخيم بالفعل الى
النزوح عن منازلهم جزء بالتاكيد نزحوا عن
المنازل تحت الضربات وتحت الغارات وتحت
القصف جزء اخر ما زال يتواجد لا سما في
بعض مراكز الايواء المدارس التابعه لوكاله
غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين الاونور ولكن العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه والاعتداءات ما تزال
مستمره ضد مخيم البريج ومخيم المغازي
لكنها لا تتوقف عند هذا الجزء الشرقي من
هذه المحافظه الوسطى ولكنها ايضا مكثفه
بذات الدرجه في الجزء الغربي بمعنى منطقه
النصيرات ودير البلح والزوايده ومجمل وال
المغرا ومجمل هذه المناطق التي تتكون منها
محافظه الوسطى يسقط فيها شهداء وجرحى جراء
استمرار الغارات والقصف الاسرائيلي من
مستشفى ناصر في خان يونس مراسل الجزيره
والالد دحدوح شكرا جزيلا
لك